kardi be indicted by a grand jury on  Friday the new charges against the money  wrapper are sealed until her arraignment  scheduled for next week but we know  they're connected to misdemeanor charges  that stemmed from an altercation at a  strip club in New York back in August  cardi and members of her entourage  allegedly threw chairs and bottles at  bartenders two of whom were said to be  injured car D was originally arrested  and charged with assault and reckless  endangerment she rejected a plea offer  from the district attorney in April and  cardies lawyer claims the rapper didn't  injure anyone during the incident  [Music]  the indictment news comes less than 24  hours after cardi received a big honour  ASCAP songwriter of the Year award in  Beverly Hills she's next set to appear  at the Beatty Awards on Sunday et has  reached out to party's attorney for  comment  [Music]